wir sind heute in namibia und machen ein
video zum autofahren
das ist max max hat ein auto gemietet
max steigt in das auto ein
das ist der autoschlüssel max steckt den
autoschlüssel in das zündschloss
er lässt den motor an er tritt die
kupplung und legt den ersten gang ein
jetzt fährt max los
[Musik]
in namibia gibt es linksverkehr max
fährt daher auf der linken seite der
straße max bringt er will abbiegen
im seitenspiegel checkt max ob die
straße frei ist
zufällig ist die straße gerade frei max
liegt jetzt rechts ab max fährt jetzt so
julia max ist bei julia angekommen julia
wartet schon vor der tür
wenn sie sind schon zu spät
da läuft ein jahres über die straße max
muss eine vollbremsung machen was dort
so bist du dich doch julia maxi
mittlerweile angekommen weil der partie
zufällig ist auch hier gerade haben sie
sich noch angeschrieben im
straßenverkehr
jetzt haben sie sich aber schon versöhnt
es ist nicht schlimm dass du schlecht
wer du bist nach
so geht das hier in namibia im
sonnenuntergang kann sich schon alle
wieder versöhnt jetzt feiern wir
zusammen danke dass ihr zu gesehen habt
und wir sehen uns nächste woche wieder